we are now live on youtube so if anyone
misses out on the uh in the zoo me they
can definitely refer to the meeting on
youtube later on
and we'll be starting within just five
minutes
hello everyone a warm good morning good
afternoon or good grieving in whichever
part of the world you are
i would like to welcome you all for the
two days workshop on genomic data
analysis
this workshop will help you get started
with genomic data analysis program which
is an online bioinformatics training
program that will provide an in-depth
overview of concepts and analytical
tools used to study genomic variation
the program is designed to introduce
students clinicians and researchers to
the role and applications of genomic
data analysis to study genomic variation
and apply genomics in translational
sciences to improve diagnostic accuracy
predict which drugs are likely to be
effective in patients and contribute to
the monitoring treatment and diseases in
individuals and populations
each week participants will meet online
to discuss various aspects of ngs data
processing genomic data analysis and
interpretation
after the first introductory lectures
participants will have the opportunity
to get guidance and work on curated
datasets or develop independent projects
that leverage the tools and concepts
covered in the program
in this today workshop we will discuss
about genomic sequence alignment and
data visualization
genetic variation and mutation
application of genomics in research
aspects of ngs data processing genomic
data analysis and interpretation
and introduction to sequence analysis
and r and python as well
i would now like to take this
opportunity to introduce myself my name
is sunalika ray and i'm the omixlogic
community manager i'm responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our community
that is managed by fine biotech
so before we start with today's workshop
i would like to introduce us for the
ones who have joined this webinar for
the very first time
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 15 000 users around
the world have completed the training
programs and due to this fast growth our
team is working with local and regional
coordinators
that are helping refine the local
program logistics and leverage our
online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
the programs follow a project-based
learning approach which uses research
great tools to analyze data from top
peer reviewed journals
omixologic training has been completed
by over 10 000 participants from 162
countries in over 300 workshops for six
different specialization tracks
which include oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
i am honored to introduce the founders
and team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one of his major
projects is the establishment of trouble
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brosky is the director of
troubled bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia panoff is an expert
bioinformatician avi tatovsky leads the
development of the tea bioinfo platform
dr hartreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques on biomedical data
and looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications and peer-reviewed journals
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for omics logic training
and research fellowship
dr raghaventran lakshmi narayanan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with an experience in large scale
analysis of multi-omics data and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
so that was all about our company and
our team members
now to get started with today's workshop
the first very important thing is to
sign up on the learn.oxlogic portal so
that we can get started and also
go along with the mentors
to follow the pipelines on the server
uh i just had a text in the chat box
that i wasn't audible was it for if
anyone else has been or was it just for
nadia
try to rejoin
the same link
thank you josie for sharing with um
us the link to the portal
so for those who have already created an
account on the portal they can proceed
further
with updating their profile
but those who are new to the uh workshop
and also are new to this platform it
would be nice if you just could quickly
uh create your account on the portal so
that when mentors take you through the
resources and the server pipelines as
well you are able to go along with the
mentors so i'll just give you a demo of
how you can sign up on the portal very
quickly so that you can follow the very
same steps so you just need to click on
the login button that is on the extreme
right top
and you will be then redirected to a
sign up
button now here either you just put your
mail id and password like create an
account for yourself and sign in
or you can also sign up using any of
your social media accounts that could
include your google accounts facebook
linkedin etc
so i'll just log in quickly with my
google account
and those who have already signed up can
please let me know in the chat box with
one or yes so that i know that they are
done signing up
and others if you're connected with your
uh
desktop or laptop then please sign up
now and let us know in the chat box so
that we can proceed to the next phase
thank you rajashri
okay now let me just also sign up
[Music]
thank you samridhi
now for those who have signed up on the
portal
it is very important to have a complete
profile now what is the complete profile
so it's very important that you should
add a profile picture to your account
your name should be in title case that
is the first alphabet is capital others
are small it should not be capitalized
it should not be in small letters
because this is the same format that
will reflect on your certificate
also connect your social media accounts
and add a brief file about yourself that
could include your educational
background and your research and trust
now for every course work that you will
complete you will gain some points that
will take you from a bigger level to an
advanced or an expert level and you will
be able to monitor your progress that is
the coursework that you have been
taking or have completed the
certificates that you will get after
completion of each coursework here in
your profile tab itself
so it's very easy to download a
certificate after the completion of a
particular course book from your profile
so when you click and complete all the
course all the lessons of particular
coursework will shortly take you through
the coursework and show how they are
arranged you can simply download your
certificate by viewing it from here and
share your achievements on social media
platforms for the mentors to recommend
you
and just to let you know how you could
navigate to the portal
so here is the courses icon in the menu
bar on the portal itself just click on
courses and on the right side you will
be able to find a list of tags
now these tags refer to the various
courses on multi omics and data science
the courses on multi-omics include
uh transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
epigenomics here is the list of all the
courses so you can simply pick the tag
that you would like to explore more and
get the list of courses or projects that
you would like to uh learn more about
so that was the very simple way how you
can navigate on the learn.org portal
and before we get started with the
workshop it's also very important to
make sure that you have
uh your account working on the t bioinfo
server
so for those who have joined the uh join
any of our webinars for the first time
or have just signed up on the portal
i'll be giving you or sharing with you
all the demo account credentials and you
can definitely refer to these
credentials to sign up on the portal and
run the pipeline that the mentors will
be taking taking you through today and
those who have already signed up on the
portal
they can use their same omixlogic learn
credentials to sign up on the server t
bio info
or they can also those who are
our program participants or are the
participants of research fellowship
program they might be having their
customized credentials so use
that so that was all that i wanted to
share before we get started with the
workshop now i would like to invite a
mentor dr raghavendran to please let us
get started with the um
genomics workshop over to user
thank you thank you very much nalika
am i audible
yes sir yes thank you very much let me
find methods to scratch the screen
can you see me scream
uh yes doctor ragu mindra we can
okay uh
a very warm welcome to all of you
to this session so today
we are going to
discuss genomics what is genomics data
how it is organized
and how it is interpreted
to to be such a powerful resource in the
hands of clinicians researchers and
entrepreneurs and how reading the dna
code will help us battle cancer will
help us fight off infectious diseases
and will help us even solve some crimes
so let's start by reviewing the
fundamentals of genomics so genomics is
all about dna so let's review what is
dna code so what do we
what do we already know about this and
what kind of answers can we find here
how can we analyze huge sequences of
nucleotides stored in the dna and how do
we make sense of them
just like a book the dna code is
organized as letters that form sentences
and sentences that form paragraphs and
paragraphs that form
that that are organized into
chapters knowing how to read this code
can help us decipher the full story
about who we are and to look into our
history and to understand how we are
connected to other living things around
us so dna is
short for
deoxyribonucleic acid so it's a long
molecule composed of two chains that
coil around each other to form a double
helix this double helix carries genetic
instruction for development for function
for growth and reproduction of all known
life so this all this includes this all
known life enclosed multi and single
cell organisms and as well as many
bacteria and even some viruses so
yeah so the dna code contains directions
or recipes for life including the
capacity to grow including the capacity
to reproduce and including functional
activity that characterizes the cells
and including the continuous change that
proceeds until the cell is uh cell
deaths dies off
since life is a condition that
distinguishes animals from plants
animals and plants from inorganic matter
understanding this dna code is
synonymous to understanding life itself
so
the instruction for life of a single
cell under and also a life of a complex
organisms like us uh humans which
contains over 37 trillion cells right
each cell contains the same dna which is
stored in a
nucleus
when cells divide
as they do when new organisms is formed
are uh or when new cells has to be
generated we see how this dna is
organized the nucleus is opened up
inside we discovered these tightly
packed strings that
can be visible under a microscope these
are chromosomes chromosomes contains
different genes each one of our cells
contain 23 pairs of chromosomes one
chromos one of them or one of the
chromosomes come from uh one half of the
chromosomes come from our mother the
other half comes from our father
yes so unique
this unique structure of chromosomes
keeps dna tightly wrapped around in a
stool uh trapped around around proteins
like a spool and these proteins are
histones so with without such packaging
into tightly wound
chromosomes dna molecules would be
extremely long to fit inside the cell
for example if all of the dna molecules
inside a single human cell were to be
unwound from their histones and to be
placed as end to end as a single stretch
a single string that would stretch
to
reach to six feet so the largest
chromosomes uh chromosome of all the
chromosomes is chromosome 1 which
contains about 8 000 genes and the
smallest chromosome is chromosome 21
which contains about 300 genes so once
the cell division is complete the
information on the cell that is stored
in the dna helps the new cell
know what to do to continue its function
that it will work on for the rest of its
life and preserve the dna that it has
been passed on from its parents and to
pass on to the next cell and in the
meantime the dna that contains
instruction for various functions in a
cell must perform to grow and maintain
life and function therefore the dna
contains both
both the necessary ingredients like
all the recipes that is required for the
cell to function and all the other
instructions that is required for the
dna to be stored and accessed at the
specific time together all of the
specific code of chromosomes that we are
dealing with that we are discussing with
is called a genotype the product of this
code and how it interacts with the
environment is called a phenotype a
phenotype can describe a single cell a
tissue an organ or even the whole
organism a phenotype of an organism
could include height size weight or
activity
and phenotype of a cell could include a
specific function its size its shape or
morphology and
its composition so
dna is made up of
nucleotides at the basic level at the
base it's a fundamental level the dna is
made up of nucleotides a nucleotide is
made up of a sugar called deoxyribose
and a nitrogen containing base and a
phosphate group so the nucleotides are
joined to one another in a chain by
covalent bond that forms between sugar
of one nucleotide and the phosphate of
the next resulting in an alternative
sugar phosphate sugar phosphate backbone
so each strand of a dna molecule
consists of a sequence of bases that is
complementary to the basis in the
opposing strand so the pairing between
these complementary bases is what gives
rise to the characteristics double helix
shape so in this structure adenine is
bound to thiamine and guanine is bound
to cytosine so to understand how dna
works and to read its sequence a special
project was aimed at decoding dna
that was launched in 1990 so this
13-year long project was initiated in
1990 and is focused on determining the
dna sequence of the entire human genome
so scientists set out to determine the
dna sequence and the location of
estimated uh
100 000 human genes at the time of its
at the time of the initiation of this
project
many at that time believed that once we
had the sequence we would quickly be
able to determine where all the genes
were and this process of reading the dna
sequences and piecing them together
found the
laid the foundation of what we are
doing today led the foundation for
genomic study and
the foundation for all the other omics
study that is thriving today
yeah
so but simply reading the code and
annotating it uh
became a much longer process than the
than sequencing the genome itself and
the human genome
project itself today there are several
different competing human gene databases
with many thousands of differences among
them although the number of protein
coding genes has gradually converged and
the number of other gene types has
exploded so the latest count has found
over
consistently has found over 22 000 genes
long since the human genome project was
completed so we have around 22 000 genes
yeah
protein coding genes and that forms only
one to two percentage of uh
content that we have in our uh whole
genome so
so in brief the dna is stored in the
nucleus and it is organized into
chromosomes and into specific g regions
and some of these regions are easier to
read and to access and to be evaluated
for
for
for the functions and these easy to read
from easy to read uh regions are called
protein coding genes and protein coding
genes are the sequences or the
genes or sequences that is used to
produce proteins so how it is done it
the central dogma of molecular biology
describes how this is done this is done
involving a two-step process
transcription and translation by which
the information from the gene is is
converted first into rna and then to
protein the information flows from genes
to proteins through dna being converted
to rna and rna being translated to
protein so in each step of this
transformation we see how the dna code
is used first for transcribing the
source code to a working repository of
rna where some code is modified and some
code is not used at all and then it is
released for producing a functional
product called protein so this process
is
has facilitated
several key proteins one of which is
called is processes facilitated by
several key proteins so one of which is
called dna polymerase this dna
polymerase is a one which attaches to
the dna uh as it unzips to replicate the
dna to form single strand
to single strand and
and then it adds complementary bases to
the single strand and creating a second
workable copy this copied dna code can
in principle be used in other cells also
but
but
yeah
it is yeah can be used in other cells
also but it is also important to make
sure such a replication process goes
without any mistake so that
the cell doesn't end up with
with a different set of copied copied
dna than to the original set and the
cell also has a lot of mechanisms and
other
products and instrumentation in protein
complexes that are designed to prevent
this error or in error correction
mechanisms also so
each gene
as we saw
is a recipe for certain protein so the
gene sequences encodes instruction from
which a protein can be made and
the dna sequences encode the instruction
from which the protein can be made so
proteins are the products of amino acids
which are encoded by the three uh
sequences or try nucleotide sequences
that are called codons that are stored
in the dna so the dna sequences in
they are read uh
read by the jump of three first three uh
three uh sequences are read and then
converted into one amino acid and then
it goes there next to three and then
goes the next three so a codon is a
sequence of three nucleotides that
corresponds to specific amino acid or a
stop signal during a protein synthesis
process once a right place on dna is
copied over it is prepared for
translation by forming a messenger rna
that is exported from the nucleus so the
translation happens uh in the
cytosol not in the nucleus so in humans
we saw genes are very important and they
make up protein
and in human genes vary in sizes from
few hundred dna bases to more than 2
million
dna bases or 2 million nucleotides the
keratin associated protein for example
is 447 nucleotide long but whereas
cntnap2 gene has something like
more than
more than 200 yeah more than 2 million
nucleotides so the number of genes also
varies between various organisms for
example the influenza virus has only 11
genes while the grape genome has over 30
000 genes so
the information is not uniform across
the different organisms neither the
information about coding proteins is
uniform across the genome itself so the
genes are not just sequences of
nucleotides in fact they have regulatory
sequences at both the ends of the genes
that is upstream and also downstream
this regulatory sequences controls the
level of transcription of each gene so
inside the gene sequence itself there
are protein coding regions called codons
or exons and non-coding regions called
introns the cells machinery perform a
process called splicing that will leave
out or that will exclude the introns and
then include only the exons before the
gene is translated into proteins and the
extraordinary length of some of the
genes has enabled the presence of
introns and this
presence of introns and multiple introns
provides a mechanism for generation of
transcriptional diversity through
alternative combinations of different
axons at different levels
so the translation in the cell is done
by a ribosome which can read the mrna
sequence and assemble the protein and
this protein can be uh can then fold
into a functional form or functional
structure so
can you see my yeah i think yes now it
is working yeah so when we want to
understand the function of a particular
protein we typically combine the
information about its chromosome
position about the coding sequences that
it has about the regulatory region about
the structure as well as functional
features of the protein and about
all these information which are
understood through thorough experimental
validation and
or its comparison to proteins from the
same family or proteins that has the
same structure so now we understood the
context of what is dna how it is
organized and how it is used and how it
is
translated to form protein which are the
machinery
that defines the characteristics or that
defines the phenotype of the cell or it
defines the functions of the cell so
let's discuss how to analyze this dna
code let's look at the sequence
alignment and identification of variant
that have functional consequences on the
phenotype of the biological system
currently under study
so let's go back to a little bit of a
history so the year 2020 marks a 70-year
mark since the discovery of a structure
and function of dna molecules it took
almost 50 years from the time
to sequence the first human genome but
soon after the technology evolved and
exploded rapidly and by 2050 we have the
1000 genome project which brought a
significant number of whole genome
sequences to the research community and
in 2018
we have over 100 000 whole genomes that
that were sequenced and today this is an
ever increasing number of uh there is an
ever increasing number of different
omics datasets that are available that
will describe cellular and subcellular
process in a detail that is that that
cannot be imagined uh something like 50
years ago
so
the oh makes the multiple omics that we
just that you just heard aims at a
collective characterization and
quantification of pools of biological
molecules that translates into structure
function and dynamics of this organism
on multiple organisms the ohmic
technologies are used to explore the
roles relationships and actions of
various types of molecules that make up
the cells open organisms many types of
omics data that can be generated using
high throughput sequencing or negligence
sequencing
can show detailed information about
genomic variants epigenomic regulation
phenomic data types and
the different transcriptomic states of
the uh
cells that we have in our study
the suffix ohm one used to define
various field actually originated uh
from um
in the 20th century
in the 20th
in the 20th century when genome was
first coined in germany in the beginning
of uh yeah in the in the 20th century
the word genomics refers to the totality
of the genomes or the study of all the
gene all the genes of genomes that is
present in the
cell a genome is an organism's complete
set of dna including all of the gene as
i mentioned in contrast to genetics
which specifically refers to study of
individual genes and their role in
inheritance and
and their characteristics that defined
from this inheritance genomics aims at
the collective characterization and
quantification of all the organisms
genes their interrelations and influence
on the organisms
as a result of such effort we can now
detect differences which can be harmless
or differences that will lead to serious
issue when a gene is produced so just
like any code we can expect the dna code
to contain mistakes so these mistakes
occur as a result of copying the dna
source too many times as a result of or
as a result of various stresses that can
interfere with the with this copying
mechanism that
that is inside the cell
so to understand how genomics is used we
need to understand the analysis
approaches to
dna codes specifically how we can
identify the changes or how we can
identify the mutations that characterize
them and to interpret the significance
of these changes that we uh naturally
observe or that we observe when we um
when we sequence the
dna so mutation can actually happen in
several different ways so one form is
substitution a substitution mutation is
is something that can cause several
consequences to dna code but it implies
a minimal change that only leads to a
single nucleotide change so when one
nucleotide is substituted with the other
nucleotide it's a straightforward
substitution an insertion changes
insertion however changes the number of
dna bases in a gene by adding a piece of
dna as a result the protein that is made
by the gene may not function properly
because the reading sequences have
completely changed due to the insertion
of this one or multiple dna bases
a deletion mutation however changes the
number by removing one or certain pieces
of dna small deletions may remove one or
few basis within a gene while larger lip
deletions can involve removing an entire
gene or entire exon
of
several neighbor
stated dna sequence may alter the
function com completely uh
completely
alter the function of the resulting
protein and that is going to interfere
with the cells processes so a
duplication mutation or duplication even
consists of a piece of dna that is
abnormally copied one or more times this
type of mutation also alters the
function of the resulting proteins and
which will also interfere with the cells
machinery so
a specific type of variation can lead to
harmful
results for example a change in function
is harmful and this is called uh yeah
this is called mutation or in the other
way uh when when the changes in these uh
variation is not uh is not harmful then
that will that will not be uh yeah that
that is not a
um
that's a neutral mutation or that is no
mutation yeah
yeah that is a variation so for example
in this case uh
variation causes the eye color to change
while uh mutation causes
some really
horrible deformities and functional
losses
so when
when these genomic variants are
discussed both mutation and
both the term mutation and polymorphisms
are used interchangeably but
by convention
by convention in human genetic research
any genomic variant
with the population frequency of less
than one percentage is termed as
mutation
while
any genomic variant with the frequency
uh of greater than one percentage is
termed as polymorphism so this
distinction based on the population
frequency uh
based on the population frequency of the
variant rather than the type of the
variant is
is based on the variant of the type
rather than the type of variant or its
possible functional impact
however as a rule rare mutations that
are rare that is even less than one
percent uh um
observations tend to have functional
impact that deviates from the wild type
a yield to higher highest yeah yield to
higher signal to noise ratio for
detection of a genetic influence of a
trait or a rare mutation that will have
functional impact
can have
very drastic effects in the uh
in the uh yeah influence of the trait in
contrast polymorphisms that is observed
tend to result in less functionally
deviant genomic variants it will not uh
it might not uh however it might not
cause
severe deformities or severe
functional uh
impact of the cells or of the organisms
in study so
uh yeah however it is also worthwhile to
think or it is also worthwhile to keep
in mind that these rules uh there are
exceptions to these rules it is also
observed that polymorphisms can be some
of the specific polymorph polymorphisms
can be involved a loss of function and
some of the
simple variations in
in gene mutation
can lead to
no loss of function at all so
so a single nucleotide mutations can be
of several kinds so this is a single uh
nucleotide mutations uh substitution
mutations can be of several kind one of
this kind is mis sense mutation which is
which changes only one dna base pair and
that results in a substitution of one
amino acid for the other in the protein
made by the gene a nonsense mutation
however changes one dna based path that
prematurely causes the cell uh causes
the
cell to stop building the protein or it
introduces a stop codon in the dna
sequence that
prematurely stops the length of the
protein
that is being synthesized and this type
of mutation
results in a shortened protein which
will not or which might not function
properly at all there is another type of
mutation which is a frame shift mutation
where an addition or a deletion of dna
bases completely changes the frame of
the
genes reading
as i had introduced you before the
codons are read three bases once so when
you delete or insert one or few bases
this reading frame changes and by
reading by changing this reading frame
frame shift mutation occurs and this
will result in a protein that is
completely different from the original
or completely different from the wild
type protein and this could usually
be result in a non-functional protein so
to summarize these different genomic
variations
genomic variations can be of several
different types so when when analyzing
the genomic variance or genomic data we
are looking to find and characterize
this changes in the dna code and
associate such changes that we are
either observing
to the phenotype or to the different uh
cells characteristics here are some of
the acronyms and some of the words and
jargons that you have to remember
about genomic variations snps and smvs
so snv is a single nucleotide variant
where
a single nucleotide change that may or
may not be present in the population
basically this means any change from the
reference genome that we find in a given
dna sequence above the
level of technical error so snp is a on
the other hand is a single nucleotide
polymorphism where a nucleotide is known
to be altered in a proportion of
population and typically considered to
be prevalent in approximately uh more
than one percentage of the population so
this is a pop single nucleotide
polymorphism ah is there
is a mechanism that causes blue eyes and
green eyes and different eye colors in
the
in our in our in different human races
so
another form of acronym that you should
remember is copy number variation where
the same gene is that is encoded or same
gene is being copied multiple times and
is present in
different number of copies across
different cell types or occurs different
conditions of the
cells that is under study so such
changes
involves a such changes
as well as the characteristics of these
different variants are commonly
referred to as genotype of the cell or
genotype of the organisms so this is
what we are studying by
understanding or by sequencing the dna
sequence and by trying to analyze the
dna sequence we are trying to understand
the genotype of the organisms or we are
trying to understand the genotype of the
cells so uh the bioinformatics
technology that will allow you to
generate the digital information from
these biological samples is called
next-gen sequencing or high throughput
sequencing this technology was first
developed during the human genome human
genome project as as discussed ago and
has evolved tremendously since then so
over the years many different sequencing
techniques were introduced and they were
developed and perfected to study whole
genome sequences of the of multiple
organisms those sequencing platforms use
variety of variety of read lengths so
read lengths is the length of the
dna sequence that can be read at once
and this
this varies by different sequencing
platforms there are but in general they
can be
divided into short read sequences and
long read sequencers so the benefit of
the short read sequences isn't that
because they are short but they can be
extremely inexpensive and they can be
generated in a massively parallel manner
with billions and billions of uh reads
being generated in a single run so uh
the cost uh when the cost needs to be
kept down and when you have to sequence
multiple
different samples and and you have to
perform a lot of times
and the read count has to be really high
and then short read technologies makes
most sense while long reads on the other
hand can resolve regions of genome that
are inaccessible or that are inherently
not possible to assemble due to the
length of the short reads
because these regions can involve repeat
sequences and those repeat sequences may
uh may have maybe uh
those repeat sequences may um interrupt
our uh read mapping process so um so in
that case long read sequences have
advantages over short range sequences
while dealing specifically with those
regions which have repeat sequences and
latest advancements in recent
advancements made by oxford nanopart
technologies for example under right
conditions under perfect conditions
under perfect high quality dna can even
produce reads up to 1 million bases that
is huge so
this technology allows researchers to
explore the genetic variations like
never before down to a single nucleotide
resolution whether
whether you need to identify specific
variants that
from a focused set of regions or to look
more broadly about potential
different variations or causative
variations or to look for um yeah or to
look for
differences or variations in
the number of
number of variations in
the number of times a gene is being
copied so these are all different
explorations that one can perform so
based on this whole exome sequencing or
whole genome sequencing can both offer
effective solutions based on your
question to what to look for and how to
design your data
whole exome sequencing or whole genome
sequencing as i mentioned can be both
effective so whole exome sequencing is a
targeted
method to
sequence all protein coding regions in
the genome it offers reliable and
sensitive detections of coding variants
and it is fast and it is uh cost
effective as it sequences only
fraction of what the whole genome
sequencing is going to perform whole
genome sequencing on the other hand
provides a comprehensive view of the
genome including coding non-coding
mitochondrial dna and everything that is
present in the cell so it is reliable
and sensitive as well but in but
includes but yeah it is it is
the process is uh
complicated and it also uh it can
provide you
with the necessary information about uh
detection of
different variant types that is under
study or that is under question and
these variant types or these variations
and mutations uh these variations are
not
limited to
coding regions
alone because we are sequencing the
whole genome um
yeah
so now let's uh understand about how
this process is being employed and how
this has been done in a very very short
intro so the ngs technology that
captures uh
the ngs technology that sequences the
dna basis actually captures and
generates
this digital data using several steps
here the whole genomic dna is isolated
and then it is sheared and it is
shattered and sheared and placed in a
flow cell so inside the flow cell the
dna fragments are amplified using bridge
pcr amplification and then the flow cell
is inserted into the sequencer the
sequencer machine uses image analysis to
capture each and every nucleotide in
this flow cell fragments by analyzing
the visual
patterns and converting them into
sequence of letters that is tcga that
are the nucleotides that forms the basis
eventually the sequencer will produce
reads typically of 30 to 300 base pairs
base pairs in length so this sequencing
data that is emerging or that is coming
out of the sequencer is stored in
several different file formats so for
example a fastq file format will provide
us reads with both
will provides provide us the reads from
the sequencer and it is text-based file
format this stores the nucleotide
sequences of reads and the quality
scores for each letter that is sequenced
the fasta format
on the other hand stores the
representing dna and protein sequences
and this is typically uh reserved for
the reference file of the genome or
reference file for the genome to which
the reads that are in first q files are
matched to then we have the genome
transfer format which contains the
genome annotation for example a genome
transfer form a gtf file will store the
start and end of each genomic element
like exon like isoform are like gene and
and other sequences uh other elements
that you find in the whole genome
sequence so uh
so in
in
can somebody mute their
microphone please
yeah so in short a faster file contains
a genomic sequence itself with um
with a line that's starting as a with
the with the line that starts with the
greater than symbol which uh which is a
header that uh describes a sequence and
this is uh and describe the sequence
um
for example this header describes a
species from which the sequence is for
from which for which the dna sequence
belongs to
in this case it's from a virus in this
case it's from a uh fructa fungus
so a fastq file on the other hand is
also a text based format but it's stored
the sequence and it also stores the
corresponding quality scores of each and
every uh letter that has been sequenced
so both the sequence both the sequence
letter quality scores of each re
are encoded in a single ascii character
so a fastq file normally includes
information about the name of the read
its length the raw sequence letters and
the quality values for each sequence for
each nucleotide depending upon this uh
sequencing method that has been employed
fastq files can be quite large sometimes
over several gigabytes in size profile
so to analyze such ra raw data
many different tools for genomic data
analysis are used these analysis tools
include alignment of reads and full full
sequences analysis of relationship
between sequence and their evolutionary
divergence and measurements of gene
expression and relationship between
sequences and structures as well as
relationship between somatic and
germline variant calling methods and
multiple different uh techniques that
will characterize somatic and germline
variants so the platform the tbio info
platform
yeah the tbio info is a big data
platform that can be used to perform all
of these analysis and many other using
an intuitively user friendly interface
so the sequence alignment that i
mentioned ago can refer to two types of
alignment the sequence alignment to a
reference in which case it is called
mapping so where you have the first
queue files and these files are
from the sample and you wish to align
these files or reads to its best
position on the genome to find whether
the sequence in the read or multiple
reads reveal variation from the
reference which are in fasta format so
another alignment another type of
alignment which is multiple sequence
alignment this is what you do when you
have multiple consensus sequences that
you would like to compare each one of
these sequences
for their differences or for their
similarities and develop an
understanding between them in terms of
how the sequences or portions of these
sequences are conserved or portions and
sequences are
varied so in many cases uh these
multiple sequence alignments are used to
find structurally important variation
and it it can also be uh yeah
structurally important variation in both
nucleotides and also in protein
sequences
so
yeah so when we have the first q files
ready from the sequencer and when they
are ready to be analyzed there are
several important steps to be considered
for performing the analysis these steps
include preprocessing mapping variant
calling and annotations so for
for each task you can connect analysis
jobs to a pipeline each one of these
various inputs
a pipeline will have various inputs and
each of these
algorithms in this pipeline will have
multiple outputs and
a pipeline is defined by joining several
algorithms together from where uh the
output of one algorithm
straight away or directly uh feeds to
the input of the other algorithm and in
t bio info platform
the
outputs at each every step is
is is presented to you and is given to
you and you can
analyze or you can visualize where the
information is changed and how the
information content is built upon and
how the information content is
maximized at each step of the
at each analysis step of this pipeline
so
yeah
however yeah to carry out a genome-wide
analysis study for example
we use our researchers use two groups of
participants let's say
people with the database are people with
diseases being studied or people with uh
without diseases sometimes uh this
genome-wide association studies can also
be performed uh to identify certain
variations of
disease or conditions
that we have in hand so what
how is this
how is this performed is when the
researchers obtained dna from each
participants and sequence their whole
genome and if a certain
genetic variations are found to be
significantly more frequent in people
with the disease compared to people
without the disease then these
variations are said to be associated
with the disease so identifying these
associated genetic variations
can serve as a powerful pointers to
understanding those regions of human
genome where the disease-causing problem
resides so the methods that i just
mentioned before
downstream analysis or visualization and
somatic mutations can help us understand
and can help us relate these
genetic variations to these
different
to these different regions which might
or which will might be involved in
causing diseases or causing problems so
yeah so in this case it's it's easy to
understand or it's easy to uh observe
that uh chromosome 14 has a higher
mutational rate uh that is that could be
involved in the
disease causing
state
so
downstream analysis will uh will
actually identify mutations
s p variations and these mutations and s
p variations can be presented in
multiple different ways depending upon
the purpose of analysis and in this case
it can be presented in a tabular format
or it can be presented in a simple
a graphical format depending upon
depending upon this
depending upon the kind of report that
you are generating based on the analysis
that you just perform so this this
program is actually designed to
help you learn more about these analysis
methods and their applications in
various project examples so uh
this genomics program will include an
expanded overview of key concepts
principles and examples of genomic data
analysis now i want to invite dr
harpreet to present you with a couple of
uh of such analysis which can be
performed in tbio info big data platform
so over to you dr hartreet and then we
will come back for the um
for
how to
briefly talk about how such genomic
studies can be used in real life uh can
i hand over the podium to dr harpreet
for for a demonstration
thank you dr
um
thank you for very nice session
so already dr aguinder was talking about
uh
like what are the different mutations
how you can analyze that how we can
perform phylogenetic analysis what is
the
advantage of such kind of analysis now
let's see how we can do that practically
particularly by using a
three binder platform
so now let me
just give me a second
so just let let's go over the server
so my scene is visible to everyone
so this is the t bind for server which
actually has
multiple sections where you can perform
various type of analysis depending upon
the data that you have then depend as
well as depending upon what type of
analysis that you want to perform so
this is very important uh plate forms
this especially for both
uh people who have
do not have any bioinformatics
background as well as for those people
who already have informatics background
but as we know that ngs data has very
large data and it is impossible to
analyze such kind of data on your own
system so this platform
uh this platform offer you
the opportunity to give that
give this
interface to perform various types of
analysis without even if you don't have
much knowledge about programming because
here scripts are already executed so
then you just have to perform like a
click on button step so you just need to
understand the logic
so for example here under the ngs data
you will find various sections like
transcriptomics that is bulk rna
transcriptomics then genomic section
then we also have a section that are
associated with micro rna or repetitive
elements under the dna and rna similarly
we have some of specific mutational
analysis section under the cancer
biology then uh
as we know that these days single cell
data analysis is like more days it is uh
so you will find specific section for
single cell data analysis similarly for
virolusi metagenomics and data mining
so now as we uh what we are talking
about genomics so one of the aspect that
so far uh doctor agar window was talking
that is phallogenetic how we can
perform multiple sequence alignment so
let's first go over one of the sections
that is under data
integration and modeling here you will
find this data association and under the
data association subsection you will
find this
section specifically dedicated for
phylogenetic analysis so here when you
find this section that is means already
example pipeline or demo pipelines are
already given there so what we mean by
demo pipeline it means you need not to
upload any data so we already loaded the
data you will understand what are the
steps that we can perform and how we can
integrate those results for example
let's take this example that is demo
wastewater
scope to msa that is multiple sequence
alignment so this pipeline where we are
comparing the samples that were taken
from particular scope to pixels
and
sorry scope to infected pieces uh not a
basin so here they have already
collected the waste water based water
data particularly from the uk where they
have municip samples
uh particularly available in the paste
water itself so we are going to this
demo
so by clicking on this
we just able to upload data
automatically where we already uploaded
raw sequencing files that were obtained
from
wastewater samples
so then why start we will able to upload
the data itself so as the uh dr raghav
was talking about fastq files so they
are the files that obtain directly from
the sequential machine so they it
contains the
so then once you have the reads next is
how you are going to align your reads on
reference you know so for example here
we were talking about fast scope 2 so we
are we were using
um preference genome for sars scope 2
and with this
algorithm that is verti 2 but i2 so this
algorithm will align your rate on
reference genome so this is one of the
mapping algorithm
so then the next step which is
automatically get highlighted that is to
create the consensus so here you will
find first option which is getting
highlighted that is per nucleotide so
what is per nucleotide module so it will
create this kind of table where you have
sequence then corresponding attc
positions
so then
once you have those position then you
will able to able to create the
consensus sequences
so once you have the consensus sequences
then we can perform multiple sequence
alignment that which that will align our
consensus sequences that were obtained
from different samples so it
automatically aligns all those
algorithms
sorry all those sequences so
specifically here the uh algorithm that
perform multiple sequence alignment
that is omega w
so then once uh at the nucleotide label
you are able to align your sequences
so then next is
because to um to study the phallogenetic
analysis we also need to convert a
nucleotide sequence into the amino acid
so
here this particular module will convert
or uh because on the reference genome we
already provided translational codons so
translational with the help of
translational codon so your nucleotide
multiple sequence alignment sequences
will be converted into the amino acid
next is you're just selecting the codon
position
so then uh
so after you able to perform multiple
sequence alignments successfully
next is how you can generate
phallogenetic tree so you will find
various algorithms here itself like a
and then you have algorithm like beast
collision b speciation you'll process
these birth death process so then
particularly most of the beast
algorithms not just consider the
similarity if they also consider the
time points so you can ah here we are
using this base patient birth death
process
uh algorithm to perform follow genetic
analysis or to generate a phallogenetic
tree
so then we um once we able to perform
the steps next a step which is getting
highlighted here that is end so once we
able to end the pipeline
so uh we will uh
able to directly to this interface where
you will able to get the all the output
files since this is an already in
example pipeline so we are immediately
able to get the results but yeah in case
when you are doing all this analysis on
your sample usually it takes sometimes
depending on how many samples you are
uploading so it can take one or two days
if you have very large number of samples
if you are just using very few number of
samples in that case it can take uh
maybe one hour or something like that
now let's look at what kind of outputs
that we will obtain
so let me first show you for example
followed in simple phallogenetic tree so
here you will find even a pdf file
this is that pdf file
for example now you have this kind of
allergenic tree where you can compare
which sequences based on the following
tree you can understand which sequences
are more similar to each other or which
samples are more similar to each other
so the sequences or the samples that are
present in the same plate it means they
are more similar for example uh if i'm
comparing these two um
for example these two samples they are
more similar in comparison to if we are
considering samples that are present in
different plates
apart from that if you have already time
point information in that case the
another very important uh
important information that we will get
that is like
which particular sample originated first
and uh what are the other sequences for
example here in a phylogenetic tree how
you can understand so if you have uh
any sample that are towards the root so
here so those are the old samples in
comparison to if you have the samples
that are in the nodes so if this length
is larger
specifically for example these samples
might be the
new one so then you can compare if you
have the date even the time information
then you can understand which sequences
are originated first or which are
originated later so you can compare
samples based on the follow connect tree
just to understand which are the
evolutionary
specifically phylogeny tree help us to
understand what is the evolutionary
relationship between different sequences
for example here we have reference
genome and this is also we just taken
another reference genome sequence just
to confirm whether the samples if they
are present in the same plate it
represents actually more similarity so
for this what we did we taken the
reference you know then we just
taken another reference you know just we
just we uh name it as odd group sample
so then when we are looking at these two
samples so they are present in the same
place it also show or conform us like
these sequences are more similar to each
other now let's look at the next very
important output so this is like
phylogenetic tree now how we can
visualize
or understand these results particularly
at the level of multiple sequence
alignment right so these are the like
final results you cannot compare what is
the differences between these so right
now you know that these sequences are
for example
these two sequences are more similar to
each other in comparison to other
sequences so how do we understand where
are the what are the positions which are
different from each other so uh
what kind of analysis or from which type
of analysis we can understand that now
let's go back to our
output so first
output that you will obtain here so if
you look at here so i'm just uh reading
its name that is and stewart it is msa
out
underscore faster dot fa so this is
multiple sequence alignment file at
nucleotide level now let's
download this file and now let me
visualize this file uh using a freely
available tool that is eugene
so now let me open the ugly
so this is the sample that we downloaded
right now so let's
open this
here
now we here we have multiple sequence
alignment at a nucleotide label
so this is what multiple sequence
alignment which we can visualize using
eugene now how we can identify where our
different sequences or all these
sequences are mutated or
where there is a mutation for example
whether you are conceiving with respect
to
reference you know or you considering a
specific sequence or a sample so how we
can find out where are what are those
mutations so on the eugene you will find
this option that is looks like a graph
so if you click on this
so here we need to select first that
reference sequence whether you want to
compare your data with in with respect
to reference or whether you want to
compare your data for example with a
specific sample
if you have like you are conceding
control samples right so i am comparing
my data with respect to the reference
you know
so this is also my reference genome and
i'm just
scrolling these samples
in this way so first i have to select a
reference genome if you select it here
just select this sequence then go to the
reference sequence
so here you able to select this
now how we can identify how many
mutations are there so we we can find
number of mutations as well as
percentage of a mutation let's look at
first simply number of mutations so here
um you for you can select this option
show distance column then you can go to
the count
so here you will find this column score
column
so these are the sequence name
and or sample names then you have this
score column that will
let you know how many mutations are
there in comparison to the reference
genome this is a reference you know so
how we can compare it so we can look at
for example this is the same sequence we
just named it different these are both
the reference genome so there are 0
mutations when you're comparing this is
the sample one there are seven mutations
this is sample two you we have ten
mutations similarly we have sample a ten
seven
where we have six mutations so this is
how we can look at how many mutations
are there now where are those mutations
we can always check that as well so if
you just scroll this
uh particularly you start scrolling this
to left to right you will also able to
identify the mutations for example here
so for this at this particular position
that is 9634
so you will find this a is getting
mutated to the t if you know that which
particular protein half the sequence
start position and position you can
definitely identify but at these
mutations so this is how we can look at
uh
how what we can interpret from the
phylogenetry then how we can on what we
can interpret from the uh multiple
sequence alignment itself is it clear to
everyone
or if anyone have any questions so far
okay daniel anyone else if you have any
specific question please feel free to
ask your question before
i move ahead
okay so if there is no more question
just go back to the server again so this
is just one example like if you have the
sequences you can do the follow genetic
analysis to understand what is the
reason or what is the old sequences how
similar they are so then what are the
different of where and what are the
positions where mutations are taking
place you can perform uh those kind of
analysis using msa so then what other
options that we have for example we have
this is with respect to the viruses
then we have specific for example when
we are comparing cancer in the normal
sample let me look uh take one that kind
of example where we are comparing or try
to find out something mutations in the
cancer
so let us go over again here under the
genomic section
so here under mutation variant parallel
analysis of mutation variant data
let's take this cancer normal mutation
analysis
or i have simple uh
already results as well
so
yeah
so this is variant calling cell line
where we already computed some of the
results as well so under the variant
calling
um
here again
as this is an example pipeline so you
need not to upload any data here we
already provided one cancer sample and
one normal sample so we just need to
click on start
so with the start we able to uh
click on
able to upload the sample then of course
as we know that in the
ngs we need to perform uh important
steps like pre-processing particularly
here we are first we are removing any
pcr duplicates using pcr clean the uh
pcr clean then put i2 to align or reads
on reference genomes of course here the
reference genome is human you know so hg
38 you know
so then with the
which is one of the algorithm uh
particularly for variant calling or
indent uh in
small indel indulge detection algorithm
so we can find important mutations
so then by clicking on the okay we able
to
calculate this
so apart from that you will find other
options as well so right now i'm
choosing stalker algorithm so then
somatic sniper
we are using somatic sniper which is
again a basin kind of uh bayesian based
uh waging approach based method so which
compare cancer and the normal sample
then it determines whether a particular
mutation p so it will provide you
somatic score based on that particular
score you can actually understand
whether a mutation higher the score in
indicates that mutation is more
important so here we are using this
particular osmatic snipper algorithm
so then we can end the pipeline
so now again once we complete the
pipeline so we will automatically get
this output files
so i'm just downloading this zip folder
i mean by it is just downloading let me
look at if there is any question
in the chat box
okay so i have already opened uh one of
this
results in the excel so these are the
somatic snipper results so eventually
from this pipeline although we will
obtain the vca files if we analyze those
vcf files now let's look at what kind of
results here we have so this is kind of
uh table where we able to compute the
result final results we have chromosome
2d shift first we have a particular
chromosome then chromosome position then
what is the reference allele so exactly
what was the reference genie
reference
reference base or reference nucleotide
in our in case of the reference genome
so then we are comparing it with respect
to cancer in the normal sample so we
have
this is
tumor sample and this is normal sample
now uh
apart from atgc you will find some of um
other nucleotides here like r g
y but it indicates so
so these are the substitution mutations
substitution means a of course a could
be uh
addiction mutation so then we also
represented for example m m indic again
indicate it is uh
addiction mutation where
in addition to a the c is also getting
added similarly you will find w there is
a t r indicate a z so these kind of
different positions corresponding
exactly what they represent now based on
the somatic score you can understand
whether or which particular mutation is
more important so let's uh here apply a
filter then just short our values
particularly based on automatic snippets
largest to highest
so larger the value of somatic smooth
sniffer score that mutation would be
more important so this is how you can uh
analyze and assess these kind of results
particularly from the uh
mutational analysis or mutation variant
calling method uh variant calling
methods apart from that there are also
the vca files that we are going to talk
about during this upcoming genomics
program where you can learn like if you
have vcf files how you can assess so
where are the what are the mutations in
a particular gene so how you can analyze
that and that is what we are going to
talk about in our upcoming session as
well as these things in much more detail
so yeah that's it if you have any
question i would be happy to answer your
question
uh no i would like pass this session
back to dr raghav
so dr raghav over to you
thank you very much dr harpreet
let me
find ways to share my spring
okay welcome back everybody thank you dr
harpreet for an expert full presentation
on how
the bioinfo platform can be used or
leveraged for genomic analysis so as i
was mentioning before the break the
platform the omics logic platform is
designed to help you
is designed to help you learn more about
these analysis methods and their
applications in various project examples
so the program in particular that we are
going to uh that we are going to present
will include many more expanded overview
of the key concepts principles and
examples of genetic genomic data
analysis and mentor support and
and all the associated uh
all the associated uh credentials to
perform these analysis so how
so let's move on to how are such genomic
studies used in real life let's move on
to the applications
of these genomic studies so what kind of
research questions do they answer and
what is the application of such an
extensive analysis of genomic data so we
will discuss few examples today and few
example applications of genomics and we
will find that the applications of
genomic studies can be employed to
characterize genomic variants or
inherited genetic variants that can
cause deadly diseases like sickle cell
anemia and that can cause mutations in
oncogenes that may cause cancer and that
can cause variations of mutations in
specific gene that might cause or that
will cause huntington's disease or that
will
cause several mutations or variations
which will eventually enable a pathogen
to develop resistance to the drug that
is used to kill them so first
upon receiving the dna sequence of a six
basic patient the first question we
generally ask is what genes are
different what genes are affected but
due to the volume of the sequence and
due to the number of variations that one
usually finds in sequencing output
analysis this is not a simple and
straightforward question to answer even
though genomics is currently being
employed and used for diagnostics in
clinical care purposes many dna variants
are still being discovered and are still
being annotated and are still being
rigorously analyzed by researchers and
by scientists from diverse teams so for
example in cancer the dna variations can
help us to determine the genetic risk
associated with the oncogenes but most
often oncologists will look for somatic
mutations in tumor suppressor genes in
oncogenes or in
dna repair genes specifically since
cancer most often occurs with age many
researchers see the accumulation of
mutations in key genomic area g key
genomic regions these accumulated
variations will occur as a combination
of driver mutations that causes the
cancer and passenger mutations that tag
along with the driver mutations and
identifying such mutations and
variations in these key genomic regions
can help us diagnose cancer very early
on or can help us evaluate the risk of
the cancer severity and to help us
well
eventually point is to select uh
appropriate treatment that will slow
down uh incurable
metastatic cancer situations so one
example is um
for a gene in particular p53 tumor
protein p53
which is responsible this protein is
responsible for tumor suppression so it
is implicated in many cancer
that this
gene prevents
tumor growth through a process called
apoptosis so some mutations in these
genes that are characterized some
mutations in these genes can lead to
loss of function ultimately promoting
tumor genesis by not controlling the
replication of cells with the damage to
dna so
this is an example from cancer yeah
those are the mutations and other
diseases like cystic fibrosis can also
be linked to individual genes like the
ctfr gene which can which can affect the
function of a channel that is
responsible for clearing the mucus from
the airways and hence
cystic fibrosis is born
and
in in the case of huntington's disease
which there is an inherited condition
there is a genetically inherited
condition from parents or from uh
from um
from
chromosomal combinations where a
specific gene on chromosome 4 has an
abnormal number of cag codons that is
repeated so this hdt gene encodes a
large
a very large protein called huntington
protein and the additional repeats in
this gene will
will change the structure of the protein
resulting in
movement disorder and resulting in
dementia and resulting in behavioral
abnormalities so in around 2015
the huntington consortium published an
excellent study of over 1000 individuals
with early and late onset of basis the
genomic analysis and targeted sequences
and whole genomic sequence whole genome
sequencing of this
data
of this analysis
from this analysis the researchers
discovered
important regulatory mechanisms that are
different between these two groups one
group which developed early and one
group which developed late on set of
disease so this study also identified
okay let's go back yeah that is a
yeah that is this one this study also
identified important mutations as shown
here in chromosome 15 that are to be
associated with the slower development
of clinical onset so this research as
well as others are excellent examples of
how genomic studies and extensive
genomic studies can help us identify
mechanisms of disease progression and
help us identify potential therapeutic
interventions using the natural
mechanisms of disease regulation so
in another example tuberculosis is a
contagious infection that usually
attacks lungs
it can also spread to other parts of the
body like brain and spine and bone etc
a type of bacteria that you all know
called mycobacterium tuberculosis causes
it but the severity of this disease is
very well known and it is still one of
the leading causes of deaths over all
over various countries today most of the
cases are used cured with antibiotics
however recently this bacteria has
become more and more resistant to single
types of antibiotics it turns out the
resistance is a result of mutation on
specific genes or specific promoters so
understanding which genes and which
promoters that are involved in in
developing this resistance to
antibiotics and the mechanism of this
resistance development are
very critical and crucial to develop new
drugs and to identify a multi drug
resistant tuberculosis infection from
which patients can be easily
saved so
in a
in another
[Music]
example that relates to current
situation viruses are extremely prone to
acquiring mutations because of the
number of times that they replicate
themselves and
the limited machinery that they have in
proofreading the replication process so
the ebola virus for example is an rna
virus that causes severe disease with a
very high mortality rate during the
outbreak that happened in 2014 and 16
the genomic sequencing efforts has been
applied in mere real time
real time
track
to understand and to
to model the pandemic spread and to
develop a vaccine as a result many
researchers focus their attention on
potential mutations that can have
profound effect on vaccine efficacy as
well as viral transmission rates this
happened in 2014 and 2016 but we are
seeing actually we are saying that
a similar track that is uh unraveling
for sars kobit 19 virus the efforts in
characterizing the characterization of
different variants and the efforts in
understanding the efficacy of multiple
different vaccines that we have in our
hand so
so in this workshop
today we reviewed the fundamentals of
genomics as well as the bioinformatics
tools and the applications of such tools
to various research clinical industrial
challenges and we demonstrated you uh
how to perform such analysis in tbio
info platform i hope
this uh workshop and such uh
today in
a session today will help you in
appreciating the concepts the data and
the analysis method that is using
genomics to learn each and every um yeah
to learn
more about each and every one of these
steps in detail please subscribe to the
genomics program that is starting
shortly and i will be happy to take any
questions if you have and please present
your questions in the chat room
and
that that will conclude today's session
thank you all for participation and
waiting for your question
i will pass this stage back on to
sonalika i think
thank you so much dr raghav [ __ ]
for
the session and it was very insightful
and
nice
to learn more about the field and also
get some good hands-on so i see that
many of you were not able to access the
server t by info so when you log in or
like create an account on the learn.org
portal it takes some time to get your
credentials active on the server so if
you were not able to sign up now just
try in a while maybe after few hours and
i'll be sharing the recording as well
with all of you and try to replicate the
steps that were mentioned by the mentors
and practice the pipeline
and tomorrow when we meet in the
workshop uh please come up with the
questions or if you face any of the
issues while running the pipeline or you
face any difficulty understanding
something then do let us know and if we
have any questions for now then please
let us know in the chat box so that we
can uh assist you with the same
now i would like to invite our business
development associate miss parster to uh
just take us through the registration
steps for the genomic data analysis
program
that is starting from jan 18th
so spash are you here with me
uh yes
uh
yes i can share this screen for you
yes we can tell you
also we have a question
uh
nylon you can't export the pie plies but
but
you can export the results that are
obtained by running the pipeline yes dr
harpreet has also answered the same
thank you ma'am and so chishna we will
be sharing the recording uh
just within few hours when the
processing of the recording is over so
you will be able to get the recording in
just four to five months from now
we have one more question
okay i believe that has been answered by
so yes bash
ah this is the program page that i i
would like to take you all to the
genomic data analysis program page
the program starts on 18th of january
and will conclude on 18th of february
now uh the
workshop that we have uh scheduled for
these two days the 11th and 12th of
january is just a glimpse and overview
of what all would be covered in the um
program and just to get you get the
interested participants started with
genomic data analysis
right so on this program page
uh marx and hardik will just take your
questions just in a while uh just give
me few uh seconds so that i can just go
to this program page and then we'll be
able to answer questions so on this
program page you will be able to find
the program overview and this
video will give you an overview about
the program and what it is all about and
on the program page itself you can see
that the schedule of each and every
session has been mentioned
the date for which the session is
scheduled the topics that would be
covered in that particular session and
also along each and every session you
will find some associated online
resources that the program participant
is supposed to go through and complete
now these associated resources are
linked to the lessons on the omixologic
learn portal so we have tried to design
this program in a way that the
participants can go through this
asynchronous training as well along with
the synchronous live sessions and get
mint guidance
and also here on the program page itself
you will find all the sessions and once
the session is completed the recording
of the session will be uploaded here
under each session and sell so that you
can go to the record
at your own pace so let's say if you're
not able to join a particular session or
uh you were not able to go to the go
through the complete live session you
can definitely uh look at the recording
once again after the session is over or
at your own convenience
now to register for this particular
program
you just scroll down on the program page
itself and you will find three levels
now to discuss about these three levels
and to help you out with your enrollment
for the program genomic data analysis i
would like to invite spash to please
help us understand these three different
levels and help the participants also
understand how they should get started
with the program and roadnet over to use
push
so thank you sunalika
so i am spaster business development
associate at pine biotech assanalic
already introduced me
and i'll i'm here to assist you with the
enrollment for genomics data analysis
program which is commencing from
uh 18th of this january
so for that uh
there are you need to follow two steps
one is to register yourself for the
genomics data analysis program
and the second step is that you need to
opt for
three
you need to opt any of the three level
of subscription as you can see on the
screen
so uh
the first level is the beginner level
the second level is the intermediate
level and the third is the advanced
level
and the fees for the beginner level is
dollar 75
the fees for the intermediate level is
dollar 105 and the fees for the advanced
level is dollar 175
now
what's the difference between the three
level of subscription
in the beginner level of subscription
you will be assisted in live group
sessions so you will be connected with
our mentors through our slack channels
and also uh in a q and a sessions which
will be conducted weekly
but in the intermediate session you will
be having an opportunity to have
one-on-one mentor support one-on-one
mentor guidance
and in the advanced level
you will
get an one month extra time to do a
project under under mentor guidance now
accept these three uh specific
resources which you are getting in the
three level of subscriptions what all
other use resources you will be uh you
will be getting is online tutorials
project examples cloud pipelines coding
sessions session recordings and also you
will be certified after the completion
of the program
and also i would like to add here that
in advance level of subscription you
will be certified with the completion of
the program and also you will be
getting a certificate of excellence
now
particularly
for indian uh contacts we have created a
upi id
uh so that to make the payment checkout
more feasible for them
and uh
to know more about the enrollment
process through the uk id so i'm
mentioning in the chat box
the
mail id where you can
ask anything and clear of your queries
so the mail id is
marketing at the rate omixlogic.com
so you can mail us at this particular
mail id if you are if you get stuck in
between during your enrollment process
now uh if you click on the select option
sonalika
uh hello sunalika can you do this for me
yeah if you click on the select option
so it's uh it's getting loaded i think
so there's some network issue
so uh here
there you will be directed to the window
where you need to yeah where you need to
fill your
car details and proceed with the payment
checkout
now yes
we are also uh providing everyone with a
early bird discount of 20
percent and those who are interested
please uh can leave their
email ids in the chat box and we'll
revert back you through the email uh
through the mail
itself
so uh i hope the enrollment process is
quite clear or if you are having any
doubts you can uh
please ask in the chat box
marx and nyla i think your questions
have been clarified and thank you dr
raghav injured for answering hardik's
question so you can definitely uh go
through the coursework and the projects
here on the portal and explore these
various types of
specialization tracks that you would
like to explore so i think this is just
for you if you just like go to projects
and you'll be able to here look at a
specific project which has used these
which comes under these categories that
is on broad stress and resistance in
potato
and this is a very pure a nice uh
project example that you can definitely
go through and
get some hands on
any other questions do we have
okay so if that was it for today's
workshop and then we can take the
questions tomorrow once you have gone
through the uh concepts and the
pipelines as well then dr raghaventhan
and dr harpreet took us through today so
now we'll be meeting uh tomorrow as well
uh one hour prior to the scheduled time
of today's
and
those who have not yet received the
invitation link for tomorrow's workshop
then please let us know by mailing at
the main id provided by spash that is
marketing refine dot bio and we'll be
able to send you the invitation
and uh the workshop
tomorrow will also have some exciting
sessions we have a speaker from biocause
dr sanjay will be joining us and he'll
be taking us through single cell data
analysis the timing for the workshop
tomorrow is 7 30 pm isd or 8 am cst
we'll be looking forward to meeting you
all tomorrow have a great day and thank
you for joining today
you